well the cost of hurricane ida hasn't
been tallied yet but it is expected to
add up to tens of billions of dollars
many thought the damage would be limited
to the gulf coast but the scope of the
destruction in the northeast caught
millions of people off guard now
forecasters warn climate change could
cause more storms like ida this week we
spoke with two experts about how the u.s
can weather future climate link
disasters
when hurricane ida blew ashore places
like grand isle and laplace in louisiana
expected to be underwater
but the devastation in the mid and north
atlantic regions were unprecedented
there were accounts of dozens of people
who had drowned in new jersey in new
york i mean it was
literal that this storm is coming for
you andy horowitz teaches history at
tulane university and authored katrina a
history 1915 to 2015. did you expect
that we would be where we are now i
certainly feared that we would be where
we are now and the sort of policies that
we make to aid people or not to help
people go home or help them find a safer
place to live
are really gonna are gonna be the story
of ida much more than simply the wind
and the rain from last weekend the biden
administration's 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure plan would support
renewable energy and public works to cut
emissions there's another bill in
congress the budget reconciliation
package which is 3.5 trillion dollars
that gets a little closer to the scale
of the problem and really makes more
investments in clean energy and trying
to move us away from
burning all the oil that is causing
these problems and making them
continually worse but according to
geology professor rob young of western
carolina university it can't possibly
protect more than 60 000 miles of u.s
shoreline it's not
about what we put on the ground
to fix or protect things it's what we're
putting in the air right now that's
warming climate that's where we need to
be focusing our energies and for people
living in vulnerable areas he says
mitigation is no longer an option we
have to have be able to have a serious
honest discussion about
what we do with places that we know are
so vulnerable
that they're always going to be at risk
and the risk is only going to go up with
changing climate
and all of those protections completed
back in 2018
it cost about 14 billion dollars it is
ranked as one of the largest public
works projects in world history well
according to the army corps of engineers
they now say that the system will be
obsolete
by next year because of rising sea
levels and shrinking levees one number
i've seen is 10 even if changes in the
climate add 10 percent to a storm the
storm's already bad right and then if
it's supercharged
that's it yeah and when he said
vulnerable areas it feels like after
what we saw we're in everybody's that's
it and everyone
across the country in those areas that
are nearby estuaries
yeah you got to think about that